I am Sasha despite what the slices I'll
be talking about some questions like
differential privacy in streaming type
models um let me start by introducing
sort of basic I mean the basic streaming
set up and then I'll move to
differential privacy after that so um
with streaming algorithms we are in the
online world right so the input is
arriving online so at each x so you can
think of the algorithm working overtime
and at each time step we get a new piece
of of the input so are we think about
the most basic scenario where you just
have a stream of numbers and are right
so at each time step you get a new
number and you can think of these
numbers is being identifiers of
something so they can be IP addresses of
I mean it it could be IP addresses they
could be social security numbers just
some identifying numbers for people um
anything you likely right so something
that's helpful is to to think of these
updates as changing an underlying arm
frequency vector so this is not
something we usually explicitly store
when we work on streams but this is
something we have in mind right so and
what the frequency vector is just it you
can just imagine is a table that gives
us for each possible number how many
times that number has appeared so far in
the stream so this is a vector that
starts at all zeros so I'll joined by a
the dimension is n where n so all our
updates will be numbers integers between
one and n all right and at first we
haven't seen any updates so this
frequency vector starts at zero then we
get a new number and we think of say we
get one and we think of the first
coordinate in this vector is increasing
by 1 all right and so when we get number
I we go to the ice coordinate of this
vector and we
increase the count of I by one cool so
this is sort of the increment only
setting this is maybe the most basic
streaming algorithms arm setting you can
imagine are slightly more general you
can think of the fully dynamic setting
where you know each number also comes
with the sign plus or minus so this is
also called the turnstile setting I mean
the turnstile model you can think of
sort of say the New York subway and the
turnstiles people come in and leave so
you have say plus when someone goes into
the subway and minus when someone goes
out ah so happens is the natural thing
when you get an update some number I sub
T at time step T and say a plus one that
goes with it say we get five and plus
one the corresponding location in the
frequency vector goes up by one if you
go to minus it goes down by one sort of
some variations on this you can assume
that the frequencies always stay above
zero in some settings in some settings
that doesn't make sense there could be
anything that sort of depends with the
problem of course you can consider more
general things you can imagine adapting
this kind of online model over anything
you could be getting our points in some
low dimensional space you can be getting
edges in a graph right but this is the
basic setting and I'll be almost only
talking about this during this talk on
this web most of the differential
privacy work has happened so far anyways
and as far as I'm aware so usually the
setting with considering streaming is
where this range of possible numbers we
can get is huge so it's way too big for
us to store this table this vector in
main memory um and also the the stream
length is unbounded and can grow to be
really huge as well so it's too
expensive to store the entire stream as
well so what we usually requiring
streaming is that making one or maybe a
constant number of passes over this
input we want to compute some statistic
of this vector arm and we also usually
want that the space that our algorithm
keeps a spoiled logarithmic in
usual parameters which is Lee's
sublinear and we I mean I haven't
written anything here about running time
but we usually want that each update can
be processed fast right let's make sense
go right so some typical problems that
have been considered um so one of the
most classic sort of family of problems
is estimating AR Kait moments so this so
the the cake moment of the stream is
just the sum of the AR Kait powers to
the frequencies right and also you can
think of this as sort of the lk norm to
the power k of the frequency vector
that's something useful to know about
are just note at least if if all the
frequencies are always positive the
first moment is just the length of the
stream at least in the basic model all
right something else is interesting
sometimes we call this the 0th moment to
this is just the distinct element count
so this is just how many different
numbers have we seen in the stream so
far at least in the increment only model
that's what this is um in the modular
model it's how many non zero um I mean
how many is how many elements in the
stream have a nonzero frequency all
right oh cool Oh something slightly
different so the cake heavy hitters so
we we say that something is AK heavy
hitter if the element is a care here if
the frequency of the of the element is
at least a kate fraction of the total
sum of frequencies so those are elements
that really dominate the stream right so
if k is equal to two those would be
elements that have liked more than away
at least have the frequency of that
entire stream so like more than half the
numbers you see you're just this one
element and generalizes to other k
um you would do the same i think so it
would still be you know elements I that
have frequency at least i would say i
mean i think the most natural thing is
again the first frequency moment over k
so this the sum of all absolute values
of all frequencies over k if it's really
turns out like if the all right so we
turn style you can you can have to two
different things in mind so in one case
it really is a turnstile type of
situation where people come and leave
and nothing goes below zero but another
application is where actually what the
turnstile simulates is the difference
between two streams in some sense so
there it might make sense to have
negative numbers as well but i think
heavy hitters sort of makes more sense
in the the case where frequency moments
are always above zero spec sense all
right oh you can ask for the median or
motor you can ask for quantiles know any
different models you can so if your
streams or edges you can ask all kinds
of things like matching size of
matchings is the graph connected how
many triangles are there can ask for the
value of the optimal k median clustering
can then there's a lot of work on all of
this I mean many problems to this type
I'll be mostly concerned with this basic
model sorry friend I'll be talking about
these problems except median all right
so when is this applicable so this
constraint that we only want sub linear
space this makes sense when of course
both the universe size so the universe
from which our updates come and the size
and the length of the stream are really
huge so it's just it's not practical to
save these things in my memory and so
you can imagine this being relevant in
situations where you have updates
arriving really fast and you can afford
to store all of them so say IP traffic
monitoring web searches update
on a social network um so these sort of
natural online scenarios but this thing
is useful so for in the offline world
actually so can you imagine having like
a large unstructured database sitting on
some external storage like on some big
hard drives and uh so say like
transaction data for something and it's
it would make sense to I mean one thing
you could do is you can put this into a
structure database but that might be way
too expensive indexing might be hard so
you might just want to at least um at
first be able to estimate things on this
large data by just doing like a constant
number of passes over the data these are
sequential passage so you don't so the
thing is that sort of ram axis or an
external hard drive could be expensive
and this is the this is something you
don't have to do with a streaming
algorithm it just goes on goes over
everything in in sequence the reason I'm
saying this is that now when you
consider this setting so in the online
setting made you may be multiple passes
seem like a strange just theoretical
model but when you're thinking of just
processing large data that's sitting on
an external hard drive doing a few
passes over the data definitely starts
to make sense ok so these why I'm saying
this and you can use to me algorithms in
sort of a first rough approximation to
compute something then decide what to do
next or sometimes it could be donating
you you can do I mean if you were
looking at say I'd be traffic going
through some router the router really
can do very fancy computation so maybe
you cannot do anything that's much more
complicated alright so the talk I'll
first um right so i'll start by a sort
of an introduction I'll show you how one
classic of streaming algorithm looks
just to give you a sense of these things
then I'll go to connections with privacy
and you will be a few different things
so I'll just look in sort of the
conjunction of the small space and
privacy requirements and I don't look at
some natural further kind of price
restrictions you can impulse with online
data and what they mean it's all so i'll
start with arm giving you a taste of
what it is one classical streaming small
space stream algorithm looks like so
this is an algorithm for estimating the
second frequency moment ah it's
beautiful work of alone matthias and
SEGA d 496 so this is a paper that
essentially started like the modern
theory of streaming algorithms there
were some really nice precursors but
this defined the model the way we
essentially no one love right now so um
so this is what we call the AMS sketch
when I say sketch you can think of this
as sort of just a small summary or I
created concise summary of what the data
is and often it will be a linear
summaries or even be a linear function
of the frequency vector alright so the
problem is again remember estimate the
second frequency moment so this is just
the sum of squared frequencies of all
the items we've seen so far so what
we'll do our first describe sort of a
simplified thing where we're just
keeping one counter like one variable
this will be our initial sketch so um
what you do is you you get a number on
the stream and you hash it randomly to
plus minus one and you got some numbers
a plus one so you add so you have your
counter set to zero at first you got
your first item you catch to plus minus
one you add the hashed value to your
counter and you keep going and you add
all these up so each item you have to
plus minus one and whatever you got you
add it to your current counter and then
you get something like you get the sum
of all these hashtags at the end so
estimator is uh just the square of this
value and sort of fairly trivial our
analysis gives you that the expected
value of x squared is exactly the second
frequency moment okay it's just a
computation oh all right
and notice though so this is definitely
true if H is just a uniform random hash
but it's also true if so this statement
is also truth h is just very wise
independent oh and then all right so we
have this estimator so we want to know
so ok so it's an unbiased estimator but
how far is it from the truth so first
thing you might try to do so look at the
various the variance would be upper
bounded by the fourth moment of X and
this is oh so you should be square here
okay you can imagine a square okay so
the variance is bounded by the
expectation squared times some constant
so this is essentially inches inequality
but you can also prove it only using for
wise independence of H what I'm saying
this is that if H is just for wise
independent and not fully random then it
has a concise description so you can
store H concisely in memory and of
course these things in gravity count
towards your space right um so this is
issue that's important for streaming
algorithms and I'm pointing this out
right now but I also be ignoring this
for a lot of the rest of the talk so
I'll kind of assume that I have hash
functions that are some kind of Oracle
that I can just query just because it
gets technical to sort of deal with the
pseudo randomness that you need to make
these things work usually you can make
them work or but it's not always trigger
all right so we have some estimator the
variance is comparable to the square of
the expected value so this is good so
just applying our chebyshev's now we
know that we constant probability we get
a constant approximation to the true
value all right and at least on one side
all right so the thing is make me want
to do better we probably want to do
better so we want to get a 1 plus minus
alpha approximation to the true second
frequency moment so here is a trick that
use very often is very useful so just in
parallel compute a bunch of different
copies of the same estimator store them
in a big table I mean not not very big
table like a relatively small table
so we want one plus minus alpha
approximation with probability 1 minus
Delta so we'll get log of 1 over delta x
1 over alpha squared copies of this
estimator arrange it in a table like
this log of 1 over delta x 1 over x
squared so what I do is in I average
each row of estimators um alright so i
get these average estimators so with
this averaging does is it decreases the
variance by alpha squared so now my
championship i know that each of these
guys each of these five guys in my case
is a one plus minus alpha approximation
to the true second frequency moment with
cause some probability and i just want
to drive down the probability a little
more so i just take the median of all
these and just by general bound i get 1
plus minus alpha approximation with
probability 1 minus delta is useful
trick so this essentially says that as
long as you can get the variance being
nice you can do just slightly more and
then you can get high probability and
good approximation okay all right so let
me start moving towards differential
privacy so before talking about just the
natural questioners of combining the
small space constraint it and the
differential privacy constrain oh how
much man of mystery civilian these
things to get the log when I doubt that
ah for each one of these you you need
sort of like all your order log random
bits because I remember we just need
this hash function which is for wise
independence so we know how to construct
you squid order log yeah they're like
pulling on your size families of these
things ah and then it's independent
random is for all these so it's
essentially all of all of the entries
case independent having a better
randomness
Edge's themselves yeah each each one of
these is independent from all the other
ones okay the different hash functions
for each one sure but you can think of
alpha is a constant and Delta's don't
think you need the recipe you don't
think it wise independence for some it
depends what probably is that yeah okay
so you need to make a channel homework
right we have pseudo random functions
right it doesn't believe okay I mean
it's definitely enough to take any
parameters for you each of these but um
all right so okay so i'm not going to
define differential privacy because
we've seen a lot of work I mean we've
seen a lot about different strategy so
far but I still need to define what
differential privacy means in this
context so I want to talk about you know
differential privacy with streaming
inputs with all one inputs so there are
some things that we need to figure out
um it's so we need to basically define
what it means for two inputs to be
neighboring inputs so differential
privacy is going to say that you know we
can't really distinguish between two
neighboring inputs so we need to say
what these are all right so we have to
option or at least there are two things
that appear in the literature are the
weakest thing you can imagine i think is
what we call the event level privacy so
event level privacy is what you get when
you define neighboring inputs to be just
streams where you took one element from
the stream and you reply if you removed
it or you replace it with another
possible element right so you took a
foreign you replaced with one so this
prison what would this sell sort of
semantically is that if you have a
differentially private algorithm with
this um notion of neighborhood the
algorithm is making it hard to
distinguish if one of they happened or
not so if all of these correspond to say
so all the four score
respond to person number for buying
something is to say that any particular
purchase will be protected it doesn't
necessarily say that all the purchases
of person for will be protected that's
why it's event level privacy okay our
user level privacy stronger so here we
say that we have neighboring so
neighboring inputs are in inputs where
you take some say subset of the
instances of of one of the elements so
say some instances of five and replaced
you know two of them this one and this
one by three so you don't have to
necessarily replace all of them so you
have neighboring inputs when you can
take some of the instances of one number
in one stream and replace them with
another number we'll fix the other
number okay oh and we actually also
allow to sort of move so when you've
changed some of this is a five you can
also move these instances in different
places in the stream the way you define
it right so you're uh me see you cannot
go back from you can replace all the
three to five take your place it face
with fire so all as a particular case or
some you know but if you're sometimes
too three cents sounds nice to flew to
my florist and some pipes stay the same
you can undo it in a single you know
what I'm saying is so you choose a
number you choose another number wanna
one other number okay yes oh so is this
so your acquaintance users with the
things are counting here yes that
obviously like the right way to capture
you depends on the application right
right but what I'm thinking of is IDs of
people doing something so each time an
ID appears it means a person walked into
a store for example each time you open
something query so we want to protect
all of your query simultaneously right
but maybe I'm counting like the
distribution of which websites people
visit okay and so one person visit as a
shop site of websites but yeah changing
one person's data doesn't isn't the same
as changing all the best of facebook to
visit that's there's not quite captured
quick this yeah I think you'd have to
know yeah I guess I was just saying like
there's some cement you're making some
assumption on the semantics of the yeah
yeah so I'm assuming right let's say
this is a perfectly reasonable model I'm
not saying it differently I didn't know
if you were doing that you would just
look at the stream of visits to Facebook
here versus visits to web pages to come
ok cool all right so this is important
the user level definition is a little
trickier to be good to it absorb it ah
maybe it's easier to think of it if you
think of the frequency vector what
happened is I have the frequencies of 5
I took some mass from there and they put
it on three this is essential to travel
ok so it makes a little more sense but
it's a little closer to the usual
privacy definitions if you think of it
that way all right ah so first question
you might ask is can we confuse
interesting things but I under the
constraints of both streaming and
differential privacy and it's something
into it's a poem that actually hasn't
really been considered much into this
feature and I think there might be some
interesting problems there so um take
one simple example which
is the distinct own estimation so
remember just how many distinct elements
they were industry how many distinct
like unique numbers did you see arm so
under say user level privacy this has
sensitivity one right because if I
remove all or some of the instances of
one number it just changes by one right
so you can just add Laplace noise one
over epsilon you get epsilon your
friendship privacy that's really simple
um however if you also want to say you
you have a database sitting on an
external hard drive somewhere and you
just want to know first you know how
many distinct people are represented in
this database so you want to do this you
know in streaming with small space but
the problem is you can't so this the
differentially private algorithm that I
just said was just as what plus noise
assumes that you have the exact distinct
count and then to the exactly sting
count you add the laplace noise however
it's so you you can't deterministically
or without approximation you can
estimate the sting counts with anything
with sub linear space um so once you
want to have both the streaming in the
privacy constraints it's actually not
quite clear how to do that here's a
simple observation that gives something
but i think i would suggest people look
into this kind of these problems i think
there might be some interesting things
there and they haven't quite been looked
at it is your question know someone
who's just scratching your head all
right so here's one idea something you
can do um there's a really great
algorithm by floods remarking that was
one of these precursors of the streaming
model that was industry uses an
algorithm industry me model before it
was defined I it gives an estimator for
distinct counts on this estimator uses
log and bits of storage it's actually
like one computer word pretty awesome it
gives a constant a multiplicative
approximation two distinct counts with
like constant probability so one thing
that's nice about
this and it's at least sure when you use
sort of a random Oracle model is that
the distribution of the estimator only
depends on the actual distinct count
value so you can do something Adam is
enjoying it so you can do something like
almost city which is first pic are
essentially Laplace noise but let's
discretize it to not worry about these
issues right so it just to discretize a
pass distribution anything that discreet
and so supports on the integers in like
ensures differential privacy um now
we're just going to simulate a new
stream so let's call our noise value ada
if ada was less than zero we just kind
of withhold the first aider distinct
elements from the stream so we can use
like space ada to do that we just count
them off and wake we don't we don't give
them to the flood remarketing estimator
if a is greater than zero we just add
new ones and since the estimated just a
function of the true value of the number
of distinct counts we get some so the
distribution is entirely determined by
that we just get some estimator whose
distribution is determined by
essentially this value so what we did is
so what happened here is there was some
cropping because you know if there were
less than ada distinct elements we just
don't give anything to the estimator but
this cropping you can think of as
post-processing you doesn't arm hurt
privacy so this is already private and
doing this cropping at 0 this truncating
doesn't hurt privacy so this is
differentially private and it has almost
the same guarantees is the original
estimator and since at most you just
need to have a little bit of additional
space if ada is negative 2 count off um
you know how many are I mean to count
off like eight items at most I usually
this wouldn't require much space right
kind of really simple but the question
is that would you suggest people to
think about these things I think there
might be more interesting algorithms
waiting to be discovered at the
conjunction of these two constraints
okay be interesting to consider say
geometric clustering problems there is
really nice work by Kobe and others so
Danny Feldman mmos Fiat Kobe and a hand
couple good they have somebody has work
on private corsets corsets are very
useful to construct small space
streaming algorithms private courses
should be very useful to construct I
think small space course in algorithms
Alex o space for the previous thing now
that's a good question maybe the quick
yeah it doesn't have to be this yet like
I'm not sure it has to be this that's
that's another interesting questions
it's not clear what space um like what
privacy does to space right it is
exactly if it requires you to have more
space it I think that's an interesting
question Thanks cool come on just do you
have an excerpt of also if you go back
to see the slide you could have added a
constant long Delta Logano delta /
excellent to your counter and then you
wouldn't have to ignore the if you just
add enough i sent it to eight hours to
make it most almost always positive
awesome current negative error in the
estimate as you're saying yeah so this
is you can subtract off later which you
can maybe some taco shells BS is iffy
okay so in this case you just have the
flat remark in love there's there's some
question here about pseudo randomness
that I haven't quite thought through so
this property I'm sure is true when you
have a random Oracle i'm not sure what
happens when you have pseudo randomness
it's something to consider not published
it sort of just for the stock all right
doesn't get a question job got covered
your John coverage great thanks John
well
great that's what I have to say about
this so now um now it will be more
privacy but still winners sort of a
streaming or if this online setting ok
so I first talked about continuing
privacy under continual observations so
this I mean usually with streaming
algorithms at least the way I have
thought about them is there you can
query them at any time and get some
estimated you like some estimate what's
happening Oh at least you can clear them
a bunch of times because they have
pretty good usually space scales like
log of 1 over probability of failure so
you can tolerate quite a few queries
right without blowing up space too much
ok so and this kind of thing totally
makes sense with privacy when there is
being updated online usually you would
like to not just compute how many so if
you're tracking the spread of some
disease you you would want to compute
how many people infected in some region
not only once but what happens over time
and you can make this a module for
almost anything you usually you want to
see what happens over time so of course
you can do things like you can let
epsilon just I mean the Epsilon's just
add up so you just run the same
algorithm over and over again with new
randomness each time eps knows that up
so privacy goes down or you could aim at
a fixed epsilon then you divide so you
sort of partition the x1 over time steps
but these solutions so like the lead to
either back promise you're bad utility
so it's a very natural question can we
do better and this the question asked
but in a paper by all these paper
scripts over here okay so uh dwarf nor
peter c roth bloom any cunning and last
question yesterday des can we track some
statistic over time so we have data safe
arriving in a stream into i described
and you want at each time step when a
new update arrives you want to possibly
update some statistic or she want is
that at each time step what your output
is a braxin
i equal to the true value of some
statistic and I mean that's the hope but
the absolute privacy requirement is that
at each time step y'all put something
you want the entire sequence of updates
at each time did I guess a girl he's on
the plan pricing the Y Sergei thank you
I used to get was now in one of these
papers why don't you guys were hoping
yes sir okay like that wait so privacy
requirement though sorry about this the
privacy requirement again is you have
this algorithm that outputs a bunch of
updates it comes to some statistic we
want that the entire sequence of updates
at each time step everything that you've
seen so far is always epsilon your
friend should be private spec says okay
so for each time step what you've seen
so far it's on the fresh your private
right and there's some nice results so
you can essentially do much better than
in a lot of cases than dividing
excellence equally over text x so ah the
original paper without so gay i show how
to compute a single counter and I'll
show you a sketch of this uh so it's not
something like is just the problem of
counting by tracking the number of once
in a stream and it sounds very simple
but it's actually very useful routine
for a lot of things um in joint work
with mu 2 and folks at technicolor
naughty for us was here we show how to
come so which are some variations on
this technique so show how to compute
time decade counters so this is the case
where you have some statistic and you
kind of stopped caring about old events
after some time so you try to discount
them okay so you can do better with
error when you have this situation you
can add less error this little shop
yesterday so there was some results I
think relate to online learning in the
original paper yesterday was so nice
work by add
and a pradeep online learning where
essentially the privacy constrain was
again essentially continual privacy I
mean privacy under continual observation
oh also the original paper had a sort of
genetic transformation for algorithms
that satisfy a certain monotonicity
property all right all these results are
in the event level model by the way I
should emphasize that oh and I'll come
back to the slave all right so i just
want to show you this nice very useful
algorithm for tracking the number of
once in the stream so now the situation
is you have a stream each time step you
get either 0 or 1 neighboring streams
correspond so this is event level so
neighboring streams correspond to change
equal 0 to 1 or 1 20 somewhere and you
just want a year's time step talk with
approximate becoming you once you've
seen so far all right so what you do is
your you so this algorithm assumes you
know the size of the stream ah this
paper by chance she a song showed that
you don't need to know that you can get
rid of that requirement but it's easy to
describe the algorithm if you know I
make this assumption just so just for
the talk i assume i know the total size
of the stream so imagine building a
complete binary tree on top of the
stream this is an idea that i'm sure
like his appeared in a lot of data
structures papers like this basic
construction but it was discovered this
race for differential privacy so you
also see this actually in streaming
algorithms for computing heavy hitters I
mean similar idea all right so let me go
back together you imagine a big binary
tree on the entire stream so each node
of the binary tree has variable all
right ah so each each each variable our
stores essentially the count of the
number of ones in the sub 300 the
variable so case all the leaves store oh
and so each leaf corresponds to a time
step any stores a noisy version of is
there 0 or 1 it
time step all right ah and then in each
internal node you start a noisy version
of the sum of the exact counts for the
two children this make sense right so
eat in ensure each each node the true
count for the node is the sum of all the
ones saw the bits in the subtree under
this note and we because we want privacy
to actually store a noisy version of
this so the question is how much noise
do we need to add the observation is
that each bit only affects the nodes on
the path to the root all right so
there's most log of say n is the length
of the stream on your log M of these so
usual I mean we know that for the
robustness mechanism this means so the
l1 sensitivity of this entire data
structures are log M so you just need to
add log M over epsilon noise to each of
these codes right and why is this useful
there is your question why is it useful
so now we're this time step say for
example and I want to compute how many
once I've seen so far so I can represent
this is the sum of the true count here
and the true pound here so the
observation is I can decompose any
prefix some so this is a sum that starts
so some of the bits the from the first
one up to the gate one I trips at any
sum like that by taking it most one note
from each level of the tree sometimes
even let it work in this case and so
cool so there at most log M of these
each one of them has noise log M 0 so
the total noise for approximating any
single prefix um is on your phone log in
basic construction make sense all right
ah so this what I'm going to show you
for continual privacy so that it can get
to some time privacy so um this is a
very useful subroutine for a lot of
things so we saw that in Adam stock
yesterday and you can sort of imagine
doing something similar whenever you can
sort of need to decompose your problem
over time steps like that all right oh
so you can see did it so it is an open
question what is the optimal noise for
this so doing it poly log and what is
the right borlaug for just this problem
of counting number of one's copies
confused for epsilon delta differential
privacy for epsilon zero we have a lower
bound that i had on the slide and then I
remove some reason of log M oh sorry
also for epsilon delta have Logan if
Delta itself is less than one of her ass
okay great Oh actually I aware that cool
but we still don't know the right order
log because always because uh the upper
bond is like at least log squared and
even the offline version of this problem
just output all the prefix sams i think
is interesting already anyways um then
again general techniques for problems
that don't easily decomposer that would
be cool oh yeah that is a good question
um shouldn't be hard on me I was headed
most anxieties easy composable acts
get Radhika boys like Maxum the maximum
of a bunch of counters so but if I've
got like d counters right then I'm
maintaining over time it's not
decomposable in terms of time it's
decomposable in like the other dimension
so he has more than one counter and I'm
just one comforting thanks thanks are
also all of these all of these are in
the user prior sorry in the event level
privacy saying user level seems harder
it would be nice to have to be able to
do something with user well Cynthia has
a comment just thinking there may be
more interesting things that at least
would require more space as far as we
know like correlations and money
products Oh want to make a comment that
this is it it's important to be able to
do this because we expected our private
algorithms in our eventual
differentially private systems for
outputting statistics would not just
work once and then die right and we
would hope that also like they scale
with time non-trivial because that would
be really nice in the sense that we
don't need to sort of multiple I mean um
we don't need this fast degrading
epsilon as time goes by that would be
nice in general let me just give one
example we know that people want to be
able to do this is analyzing
over-the-counter drug purchases for
early detection of an epidemic I don't
know what you should be computing what
the statistics are but that's going to
be a streaming setting is you guys
literally the kind of thing people want
to do you have like the infection konsa
gets over dining room
alright so now last part of my talk the
spine privacy doctor what this is about
alright this is going to be a very
strong notion of privacy so here's the
setup so if i should privacy usually the
setup is you have your database
somewhere in a vault you can kind of
work with it compute your favorite
differential pair of statistics and
release them to the world in the wild
and then they're kind of safe in some
way so question is what if so there's
this kind of security problem of you
know ensuring that your algorithms can
work in your algorithms have privacy
they can work with the data and then the
output whatever they decide to output
right oh whatever is safe so one
question is worded for some reason
internal state of our algorithm since
reviewed what if and right what if like
an unauthorized person an adversary can
view the internal state of our algorithm
for some reason so this can happen with
a security breach it can happen if you
have some kind of leak it happen when
you have like say employees of a company
that are too curious and look at things
that are not supposed to look at all
those may be the more tricky sure like
subpoenas I don't want to go too much
into it legal debate here but there is
the issue that if users that are giving
you their data if they're worried that
at some point is that it might be
revealed to a government they might not
be willing to participate so if you can
tell them that there is some that you
know your your algorithms don't really
save their data anywhere they might be
more comfortable with the UM giving you
their data so right okay um
so of course um you can really guarantee
that your algorithms are private even if
someone sees their internal state if if
you have like an offline database
sitting somewhere because you know your
internal state is the database what can
you do but in an online setting data
arrives online maybe you can compute
things without actually storing the data
and this is what happens in streaming
algorithms like they don't save the
entire input right they just keep some
sketch some summary of what the input
was you can start hoping in these
settings where we have good streaming
algorithms you can start hoping that you
could have algorithms that are private
sort of inside and out that have private
state and private output oh and I'm
privacy so have good okay so I have the
situation of the next slide so if I'm
privacy is this this concept of an
algorithm being private inside and out
oh so now we let me spend private if it
is time step okay so like I said it's
only kind of really make sense in an
online setting so again we have our
online data coming in so the algorithm
is able to process each update serve
without being bothered but then we want
that after each update the state that's
saved is differentially private actually
we require that is refresh that serves
the the state and the final would join
two differentially private but the main
point is that the state of the algorithm
is as well as the output are supposed to
be differentially private okay so it's a
very strong requirement it should be
amazing to you that I'm going to be
presenting algorithms for this because
it first seems that you shouldn't be
able to do anything other than likes a
randomized response oh well x ah and
this again can be user level or event
level and interestingly um to me in some
sense this seems like a stronger
requirement in continual privacy but we
can actually get interesting user level
private algorithms here while we
continue with private seller continual
observation it actually seems harder
um anyway so the aliens are representing
the user level okay and they will be
sort of the general strategy of like
thinking about a streaming algorithm
seen you've all like some sketch it
comes from streaming so sketches are
small space so intuitively they don't
store much about the input but they
usually are not different you private
unfortunately they might store like one
bit of the impudent that's already
revealing someone's bit so that's the
problem arm but what you can so what we
will be able to do is just store some
statistics about the sketch sort of
privatize it in some way so you knew you
see one example this is not clear what
I'm saying right now but I think you'll
see one example in a little bit all
right so let me give you a warm up just
computing so this is from the paper that
proposed differential privacy Sergei is
on this paper so this is work nor Peter
see rozeboom any cutting in our paper is
a lot of authors twosome all right so
this is not reason for computing the
sting counts for now I'm forgetting you
can get this to be small space but for
now I'm actually for getting this
requirement and I'll be assuming that
you can store something that's big
enough that mean something of size n so
I'll be storing some big table of size n
and again is the universe size so each
of your updates is some number between
one and ten all right so you want to see
how many distinct numbers you have seen
after some point in the stream so what
you do some clever variants of
randomized response so you have let's
define two distributions both of them or
minus one plus one first adjust the
uniform distribution minus one plus one
and the second one is slightly biased
towards one how slightly so that sort of
the differential privacy requirement
holds with these two meaning that the
ratio of the probability of seeing one
under this distribution and under this
distribution is almost the same color
almost the same up to the differential
privacy requirement ok so I put epsilon
here we get some order of epsilon order
of epsilon diff differential privacy for
this so you can readjust
alright so we'll start a big table size
n we initialize it by picking every
value from it from a d0 right so this
before we see the first update then when
some update arrives we pick so say I sub
theorize we look at the corresponding
entry in the table and we pick it from
the distribution do you want that
slightly biased towards one oh cool and
ok so let me see when to argue so it's
not hard to see that this big table is
differentially private at any time step
right so if you just change if you just
add remove the instances of of one
element from the stream that would mean
changing so I don't mean picking one of
the interests of this table from data
distribution and just by the way it pick
them they're close enough that you get
differential privacy I have a very
permissive you were dynamite responses
it's not it's an algorithm by these
black people saying Allah it's not
implement obviously implementable in
like a local model where is it oh you
buy depends on the world waccamaw always
make maple cake you so much I passed
without my motto is dad why it's
randomized response we're running
randomized response for every cell on
the table no you're right you're right i
it's it's not in this original local
model because you some coordination
between the difference the system to me
feel so kind of much response but I
think that's not very may be essential
for understanding it questions we make
sense this make sense alright so you can
kind of see all right so for for each
ICU we have this big table now each
entering the table that correspond it to
some element that actually was in the
stream I speak from d1 and each the
correspondence and it was not in the
stream we speak from d0 so these are
just uniform
so with expectation for those guys that
were not in the stream is zero
expectation of the entry the expectation
is excellent for those supporting the
stream so just by adding all the entries
up and dividing by epsilon we can get um
I mean we get an unbiased estimator and
so we can compute the variance very
easily so it's n over epsilon squared
ish yes it is that okay and uh it's
exactly that I think and then by channel
bound you get or even chebyshev you get
with constant probability additive error
which is order of square root of n over
x soon from this it's just a feel for
how I'm private algorithms look like its
make sense all right so ah i will be
making my way so the final thing i want
to show you is estimated for heavy
hitters but i will need this other
problem for so i had some algorithm here
don't read this i mean don't read this i
think i'll skip this further interest of
time um so this is the crop moments
problem and it's interesting because
it's not something really change Trini
ok cool i like it so okay so i'll go for
it okay you can read this later though
this is my work so this is work with
mood to their actual mirror oh this is
any of my self and Rebecca Wright and
actually have two quarters ok cool so
let me define the problem for so this is
very much like the Cape frequency moment
the difference is that we crop each
frequency top so there's a parameter top
and we just take each frequency if it's
above tau we imagine its top and then we
take the case frequency all right so
it's the the reason we do this is that
it helps with sensitivity for
differential privacy that's why no one
really looked at it I think in streaming
think it's an interesting problem
anyways so um but it is that are not
very different from what you saw in the
previous slide we can get additive
approximation to this which is order of
the cropping factor times the same
square root of n over epsilon okay oh
it's actually by approximation there is
a multiplicative factor e so let me
describe what is still just a sketch of
how we can do this how this out with
this works in it would be a useful tool
for something else alright so let's see
so one idea is we can keep each
frequency so again we will start a big
table of size n we can keep each
frequency motel um I mean we can try
that right and of course it doesn't
quite work because the say even without
noise if the actual frequency was
topless one motel that's one so it's not
a really good estimate of tau which what
what the crop value is so the idea then
is all right let's do that so let's
multiply each frequency by some random
number but you want into same so the
idea is that you know if are all the
frequencies were less than tau over 2 or
it most become tau right so they're not
distorted by much but uh right so for
them we are good their contribution is
actually two supposed to be which is
their value or at most twice that of um
alright so the next thing is what
happens with the large ones what happens
with the ones that bigger than tau over
to I want to argue that we know with
good probability or in expectation they
have a large contribution and that ok I
some case analysis shows that but if
some intuition ok so if like the real
problem any case is again when the
frequency is just above towel and you're
supposed to get out for it but
you're getting instead of like this
small value so when you multiply by a
constant I mean by some number between
one and two you sorta for spreading this
thing up so you have pretty good
probability employee actually hitting
kind of the middle of the range so in
expectation you can see that you always
get from these large guys you always get
a contribution of it please um like some
fraction of some constant time tau right
so especially the really huge they're
just like circle around like the whole
range a bunch of times so you have it's
essentially like getting a random number
from zero in town all right so this is
the main idea and once you do that the
nice thing is that each so these are so
you start a table of noisy versions of
these estimators in it then you just add
them up and you kind of rescale things
to get an unbiased estimator ah the
point here is that each of these has
range which is tau so you can add noise
which is on the order of tau to each one
of them and you just initialize with the
noise and then the updates are really
easy you have stored these numbers and
you just do the modular arithmetic so
it's like a linear sketch but it's
linear in like a different field not
feel the different group all right
that's and that's essentially they mean
that's the sketch of how this works the
other details to sort of like fittest in
counts details they're not very hard oh
so why did I do this crop crop frequency
moments I mean there are natural variant
of frequency moments because the usual
frequency also have large sensitivity so
it's hard to come I mean it's it might
they require a lot of noise so these
cropped ones require less noise but
they're also useful for computing other
things so i'll be using them for
computing the count of k heavy hitters
all right so recall k heavy hitters are
those elements of the stream that have
more than K fraction of the total
frequency there of course is most care
of them oh just comment all right just
for like skating
to know the skating is so usually
assuming we actually out because they
just give it most care of them you we
can reasonably ask to output all of them
it's what people usually do what's the
streaming algorithms usually do it's
really problematic to do this with
privacy because you have to essentially
I'll put everyone because as long as an
adversary knows that something was in
the stream as opposed to not being in
the stream that's a privacy violation so
it's hard to imagine how to actually
i'll put heavy hitters and still satisfy
privacy maybe there's some way around it
but I I don't think so I don't see it oh
but you can reasonably ask how many
heavy hitters are there and oh do you
have any a common you're there you can
try to approximate that it's some so
many settings you do expect to see some
heavy hitters for example we like web
traffic certain websites get a lot more
traffic than others maybe or together
setting since it's some measure of how
skewed the database arm so we will get
some approximation and approximation
looks a little funny wish to have the
multiplicative factor ok we will have
order of square root of K additive
approximation but we also some one on
one side we output at least the number
of cake heavy hitters minus order of
square root of K but on the other side
we have put it most of the number of K
log K heavy hitters plus order of square
root of K you actually see this kind of
approximation in streaming as well so
maybe it's reasonable I mean you don't
usually see location extreme usually you
see some 1 plus epsilon right but right
I'm not sure this is necessary that's
one question that's what we can do
alright so how we're going to estimate
the heavy hitters first let's see how
crop moments are related almost so what
we can do is we can take the difference
between the first moment top 10 total
frequency / k minus drop the total
frequency / seeking and then we'll be
normalized by the difference between the
cropping factors okay so what is this
let's think about it um if something is
a cake heavy hitter ah then contributes
one to this quantity if something is
between a seat it means make another
cake heavy hitter but it's like an a k
prime heavy hitter for some k prime you
can see k and k then it contribute
something between zero and one and if
it's not even a ck heavy hitter then it
doesn't contribute anything so this is
some number between the number of K
heavy hitters in the number of ck
educators oh cool it is actually from
the original Prime privacy paper this
idea to use this estimator oh all right
ah so now we can just you know use our
estimator for a crop first moment and
compute this and see what we get and
it's not so great so one good thing is
that here because of this normalization
uh we can kind of remove the f1 and
decay from the wake that disappears from
the noise by scaling which we still
let's move like the square root of n
which is not very good compared to k cuz
usually k is a constant or at least a
large constant maybe I mean in the usual
setting where you think of a heavy
hitter as something that has most of the
mass this is not a good approximation so
we're going to fix that and we'll do
that because um yeah by by using a
sketch so we will kind of compress the
universe into something smaller and this
n will become something else when I
should become cake order K all right so
it's a natural idea we hash so this is
our imagined frequency vector with
it's in our head we don't actually store
this what we do store is a collapsed
version of this so we randomly hash each
frequency into a bucket we add so the
bucket contains a sum of all the
frequencies of everything that hashes
into it just sort of inspired by the
company sketch it's a little different
it's also very natural thing to do all
so how many bugs do we use we use like
order K buckets all right so if we use
all the K buckets let's you'll happen so
we'll just estimate the number of cake
heavy buckets we just imagine this is
what our stream is saying wait this is
what our frequency vector is 0 so so we
have older k pockets and we ask how many
of them and we use the previous f1 based
estimator for this we ask how many of
them are I have total frequency at least
total frequency over K so both and
Prince analysis tells us that most of
these will be separated with good
probability so we get that the number
doesn't decrease by more than a constant
factor or the number of cake heavy
bucket is not less than like some
constant factor I mean then the true
number of cake heavy hitters over like
say two or something so this is one side
of the approximation for the other side
of the approximation remember our
approximation says that okay I won't go
back to but our approximation says that
the number of output wouldn't be much
more than the number of cable or cake
heavy hitters so let's look at all the
items in the contribution from all the
items that have less that that are not
kill lk heavy hitters essentially what
all the smoke look like really small
items and sort of a pretty standard and
I survived a variance and general bounds
shows that are these guys never
contribute like they don't make any
Buckethead by themselves okay Oh
alright and then we just use the f1 best
estimation so this is what i meant what
i was saying that we can keeping some
statistics on a sketch so this is sort
of like a CM sketchin we're keeping some
differential practicing on top of that
it's supposed to storing an exact see
I'm sketching this is from this joint
work so this algorithm is from this
joint work with a mood to direction
Rebecca right and this is essentially
what I have just the word there some
lower bounds for the pen privates model
oh they're nice as well but I wanted to
focus on algorithms the idea there is
that if you take the private state of a
pen private algorithm you can imagine
have the stream is private data and you
can then process this half of the stream
take the private state then use the
other half then give that to an attacker
the attacker can sort of continue to
stream in different ways to simulate
asking different counting queries on the
private part of the stream so
essentially you can use a prime private
algorithm in each state to simulate
asking many counting queries to private
data set and then you can just invoke
reconstruction results so this is the
lower bounds we were able to prove in
our paper as well and they're
essentially tied for the sting comes and
at least in terms of the additive factor
for heavy hitters um their lower bounds
against many passes that go a different
way where some interesting connection to
randomness extraction is from another
paper with a lot of authors oh okay so
this is let me see if I can notice and
Roy MacGregor KU gz here maybe not EDA
Mironov TONI&GUY ramu my thing ah kuna
and sorry 0 / yes / man what cool is it
was really nice and right there's some
interesting connections randomness
extraction and to information complexity
so if you mention place something else
soon people like see if you want to see
you like a different application of
information
complexity that's a nice paper to look
at I think oh alright this is what I
have a pen privacy essentially what i
have leave you with one open question
also about time privacy means sort of
it's not a very concrete open question
but i think it's an interesting thing to
look into so there's this general
intuition that if you keep in less space
if you have a streaming like a small
spike streaming algorithm let's make it
somehow easier to have low error
differentiate private algorithm because
you're some poor not keeping much about
the input but standing this formally
improving some theorem that says that in
some way it doesn't seem so easy i think
it's an interesting question Oh yep
right so this is what i have so in
summary i showed you some interest okay
so some interesting questions that you
can ask and new algorithms to get when
you consider private analysis in the
setting of online data you can ask for
continuous monitoring about what happens
when you will require small space when
you need to have small specks algorithms
we saw that this kind of setting
actually makes it possible to think
about really private algorithms inside
and out and we saw there's some tools
from small space streaming actually can
be used that's it thanks